I'm joined today by dr. Sandro Galia
who's a physician epidemiologist and
Dean of the Boston University School of
Public Health his new book is called
healthier 50 thoughts on the foundations
of population health it was published in
June it's so great to speak to you you
know every time there's a natural
disaster we hear a lot about immediate
disaster relief we sometimes hear a
little bit about climate change but we
don't necessarily hear as much about the
broader public health implications that
there sometimes are so talk to us a
little bit about your work and sort of
how all of these different pieces fit
together
yeah the challenge I think is very much
that as that thumb we have a very
reactive approach to disasters in this
country and in the world really that an
event happens and we have this
outpouring of attention and empathy
which i think is all terrific the
problem is that we have been terrible at
thinking about disasters as part of a
long-term continuum and I think the
challenge is that we tend to say well we
don't know when disasters are going to
happen or where they're going to happen
so as a result we'll just wait until one
happens but the truth is that we do know
the disasters that happen we do know
that they're going to happen we actually
have a pretty good sense of where many
of them will be happening and are what
we should be doing is focusing on being
prepared for events not just that we
should also make sure that we are ready
for the medium and long term for these
events because the truth is after
injuries and after the acute post
disaster face of danger passes that is
when you start seeing the other
conditions set in that result and the
long term consequences vertically health
consequences of these events which are
mostly in the mental health realm and
unless we are both prepared for events
to happen and then when they happen
settling in for a long haul effort we
are substantially shortchanging the
people who are affected by these events
it sort of seems like the inherent
nature of our socio-political system
does not really help to think about
these issues in the way you're
suggesting I mean one example would be
hurricanes
our acute events we know a few days
beforehand that they're going to happen
they have a certain start a you know
beginning middle and end and then we
enter what's called the recovery phase
compare that to for example heat
excessive heat which is probably in 2017
going to kill more people than the
hurricanes did but it's an ongoing issue
it doesn't have a particularly getting
middle and end we have elections members
of Congress are reelected every two
years the way the budget process is done
is once a year it seems like these sort
of underpinnings of our political system
and how we even prepare for these types
of issues lends itself to the acute
hurricane versus the longer-term issues
is that do you agree with that I do
agree with that I think it's a
combination of our political system as
you say and our collective cultural
attention span and we focus very much on
short-term results and on short-term
wins to the detriment all longer-term
ideas and long term solutions so maybe
concrete let's be concrete
we know that the groups that are going
to be most affected most hurt by
disasters are those who are marginalized
socially isolated and we know that
that's consistent across events and one
can with extraordinary predictability
say this is going to happen wherever an
event happens we also know which are the
parts of the country they're more likely
to be affected by hurricanes so you
would think that we could take a bit of
a long term view and say let us how do
we deal with these populations so that
we don't have these hundreds of
thousands of people who are deeply
vulnerable to an event but we do not do
that we wait until it event happens then
of course we see acts of heroism we see
injection of large amounts of
congressional monies but people
unfortunately have already suffered and
and that suffering was entirely
predictable and preventive when we think
about some of these disasters and and
sort of what we mean by prevention we're
in this is the conversation about
whether certain parts of the United
States or certainly the world is also
there are parts other parts of the world
that also have this question should be
sort of depopulated or whether they
should be rien habited after a disaster
I mean we sort of know
based on what science tells us about the
parts of the United States in the world
that are going to be increasingly at
risk due to extreme weather events are
rising the rising sea level at what
point do we have a conversation about
whether some of these areas should even
be inhabited at all it's a really
sensitive conversation right it's a
sensitive conversation to say should the
people who have made a home in this part
of the country rebuilt should should
should this be an area where we have
human habitation I think it's a tough
conversation and it's certainly a
conversation that cannot and should not
be had in the immediate aftermath of
event it's it is a it's a difficult
conversation needs to take into account
social connections need to count the
amount of disruption to people's lives
and social networks that that would be
occasioned if we chose not to build in
vertical areas and the time to have this
conversation is not when everybody is
under duress because of an event the
time we have the conversation is now
when when there is no such to rest so I
think it's emblematic of the need for a
larger conversation about disasters
their potential consequences and having
that conversation not when the winds are
howling not after the winds are howling
but at a time when things are calm and
we can actually have a rational
discussion about the scope of potential
damage when there is no immediate threat
yeah I do understand that at the same
time I mean to take the issue of gun
safety as an example sometimes you can
really only have a conversation after
there's been an incident and you know we
saw President Obama criticized for
talking about universal background
checks after the Sandy Hook shooting and
many critics were saying you know you're
politicizing this because you're talking
about it after there was an event if you
talk about it when things are calm
don't many people understate the
importance of having the discussion I
mean I think it's tough either way but I
think there's another side to that no I
see the point and I think if there ever
was a time when really when we should be
in these discussions now if they're
seeing Harvey Irma Maria probably the
last biggest time when such a discussion
was was really right in front of her
face was after Katrina about 10 years
ago so it's fine that's fine I think I
think
if these events can serve as a stimulus
for the conversation that's a good thing
that we should have the conversation but
what should happen then is we should
have the conversation keep having the
conversation rather than then stopping
and letting all this space from public
view so there's a month from now nobody
even remembers what the Hurricanes were
so what it takes for a public
conversation is is events to not just
forward it then so be it but but then
but we know we're not going to resolve
this conversation in a week or in two
weeks or even in a month but the
conversation needs to stand stay high on
public agenda I'd like to touch on some
sort of ancillary or related issues when
we talk about natural disasters in
public health there's been a debate over
the sort of carrying capacity in terms
of the population of our planet and
there's sort of two sides on this one
side is that based on our current energy
consumption we're getting very very
close to what we would maybe
colloquially referred to as
overpopulation on the planet the other
side is you know the truth is people are
concentrated mostly around urban areas
and that a lot of the planet is still
wide open and there's more than enough
space for many many times larger a
population than we currently have what's
the right approach when we want to
consider the impact of the world
population on public health in terms of
thinking about that population question
I think the right approach he is
recognising that the reason we have had
a more human impact of disasters in the
past 20 30 years and we know we know
from databases that look at disasters
are really two factors number one is
global environmental climate change that
has resulted in more natural events most
of hydrological vents and secondly is
the growth in cities and the growth in
cities worldwide there are largely in
areas that are near water and and are
affected quite a bit by this global
environmental climate change so those
two factors result in more human impact
of disasters over the past several
decades now how does one approach that I
think the approach to it is to say
urbanization by and large is a very
positive force and we are going to keep
urbanized we know that health indicators
in urban areas or by and large better
urban areas so the question is not how
to stop urbanization question is how do
we build healthier cities how do we
build cities that are safer more
resilient more resistant that events of
disasters on the other angle which is
global environmental climate change this
is one of several of the downstream
consequences of global environmental
climate change and this should serve as
a collective global clarion call to the
fact that we need to tackle that so I
tend to think that arguments about some
population size are really distractions
we know we have capacity to do a lot
better than we're doing given how we're
currently living and I think we can turn
what in the context of disasters has
been a disadvantage into an advantage if
we use if we create cities that are
built healthy that promote health and if
we mitigate human-made climate change
that is putting these cities more at
risk
well the urbanization topic is really
really interesting to me of course
you're in Boston our studio is also in
Boston and Boston is very interesting
because it is a very healthy
metropolitan area overall but within
Boston there are significant
inequalities in both access to care as
well as even life expectancy I mean
there are drastic differences in health
outcomes on a number of different
indicators in neighborhoods that are
just a couple of miles away within the
city of Boston so can you talk a little
bit about in the context of urbanization
and dealing with climate change how
inequality should be considered and how
we can deal with that in a public health
setting yeah that's a terrific question
and I've written about inequalities in
Boston as well as other places the the
truth of the matter is that when
disasters happen they did not hit urban
inhabitants even if they hit them
disproportionately with a
disproportionate burden on the
vulnerable and marginalized soci
phenomics of disadvantaged groups that
is true in Boston as it is in the world
a city like Boston is a good example
Boston is a wealthy city and it's a city
which for example has the highest
position population ratio of anywhere
else in the country
and yet in a place like Boston you have
five fold differences in the ended
prevalences of some disorders
just to the three months of work and
that has nothing to do with access to
medicine medical what access to doctors
there's everything to do with underlying
social economic cultural conditions that
ultimately create health and when
disasters happen it is the vulnerable
social anomic disadvantaged groups who
cannot evacuate who do not have the who
do not have the resources to buffer them
from the losses incurred by disasters
and it is that group inevitably that
ends up being hit the most wonderful
physical health mental health as well as
the long-term consequence of disasters
we did a study where we looked at this
for example after Hurricane sandy in New
York City showed exactly that that the
groups who were to have resources mostly
got out of the way mostly were able to
ride out the storm most of our able to
rebuild fairly quickly and then you have
the group that is marginalized so gets
affected and I think one of the
challenges we have is when we think of
socioeconomic ly disadvantaged groups we
tend to think of well that's a small
group but it's not small but we're short
on about half the country over half the
country and there is ample data it shows
that we have had a separation between
the the wealthier have been occurring
under have two countries 50% of people
and that group is having is incurring
the much heavier burden of the health
consequences of our how we're evolving a
society than they used to incur 30 40 50
years ago we've been speaking to dr.
Sandro Galia his new book is healthier
50 thoughts on the foundations of
population health I really appreciate
you joining me and these are all issues
that are certainly not going away
anytime soon so we would love to have
you back but we'd love to come back any
time thank you for having me